Thirty minutes outside Gaziantep is the town of Oguzeli.
Its newest occupants are a Japanese medical relief team,...
...which has 70 personnel and a daily caseload of more than 100 patients.
They're all self-sufficient; I bring all the equipment and medicine from Japan...
...to set up by myself and our food and the shelter I have.
Our hospital and our department are all self-sufficient.
Dr. Oba says he's not seeing as many quake trauma cases anymore,...
...but instead a rise in acute and chronic disease patients...
...as overwhelmed and sometimes damaged local hospitals...
...struggle to keep up with their normal appointments.
Many different countries have set up field hospitals here in southern Turkiye.
All are appreciated and necessary, but no two are exactly alike.
Instead, each brings with it its own sense of identity and experience.
In Japan, many earthquakes occur, so last...
...we can remember the big earthquake that occurred in 2011.
At the time, many people, Japanese people, died,...
...so we have a rich experience in how to deal with these kinds of things.
He says since Turkish rescue teams...
...spent so long in Japan during their time of need,...
...it's now Japan's time to help a friend in need...
...and build on a relationship made of shared values.
When we arrived to support Turkish people,...
...many Turkish people welcomed us and they support us.
We are now staying in Oguzeli, and we are staying in a camp.
They try to provide us meals and desserts,...
...say hello, try to study, speak Japanese.
The Japanese medical relief team...
...is expected to remain in Turkiye for another two weeks...
...until the country begins to find its footing once again.
Priyanka Navani, TRT World, Oguzeli.